all right all right I I I got I got a
list of the top 10 iconic anime endings
of all time sure uh is this the one oh
devil man crybaby had a [__] amaz
that was that was The Bleak empty ending
and love that that was a go day was
there was as well that which is a very
underrated uh ending as
Wella that was that one was okay that
was like an a ending Galaxy I haven't
seen tatami Galaxy my thing I haven't
scene parano agents yeah that that had a
decent
ending I I think it's not it's just not
as memorable as the rest of the show
yeah definitely yeah the ending didn't
stand out as much as the rest of like
the weird ideas of the rest of the show
yeah um we got baram Baran haven't seen
that I mean that's that doesn't have a
lot of story to go off of D I didn't
watch I didn't finish that I didn't
finish it either I'm I'm sad I'm sad now
yeah Hunter hun cap that's what what's
ending what is what there is no ending
all right what's next bers Naruto sh
yeah so Naruto shippon is like that's a
good example like the narut ending of
just what I mean by just the most safe
cookie cutter ending you could ask for
and that's completely fine you know
you've been with these characters oh
anohana I feel as there was a safe
ending Anana ending yeah
I'm trying I'm trying okay okay wait
wait wait I'm trying to remember I
remember crying like a [__] to
this I know I cried like a [__]
but I don't know if that was cuz I was
like an emotional teen I don't know if
it will like affect me that much at this
day and age because I remember that I
remember this was like anah was more
like Pavlov's dog it conditioned you
with that one song at the end and then
it like when secret base comes off and
then and then at the ending of anah that
the re I feel like the reason that was
iconic was just because the song just
kept going and going and I was just like
stop I don't have any tears left they
scream I found you and then the ending
starts and he just
like
why
um C A oh that had a good ending I
[__] love that show that's great
[__] show yeah okay n show she goed
goed all right all right what else next
one your line in April I didn't watch
that [__] see this is a very divisive
ending it is cuz a lot of people love
this ending and a lot of people just
thought it was kind of a cop out I
thought it was a cop out yeah uh I I
I've this is like my hot take where I
prefer the first half of your line in
April rather than the second half um it
really felt like to me some of like the
more the more interesting part of your l
in April to me was seeing someone fall
in love uh with music again yeah and
then there was a big I didn't watch it
yeah and then there was a big twist
because it almost felt like hey what
this characters going through isn't sad
enough we need to make it sadder yeah
the character drama of corset I think
like not being able to hear like the
piano and [__] like that that part was
so well written yeah and then they just
had to be like by the way the girl you
love yeah something's going to happen
I'm not going to say it obviously
spoilers but so yeah yeah that's that's
a bit of a cop out Stein that okay Stein
gate that's the one we okay we need to
yeah I I knew I was the one was on the
like tip of my tongue Stein gate I okay
that entire second half is just good
Stein gate to me needs the respect it
deserves for having a time travel story
and somehow wrapping up its like
mechanics and it story in a satisfying
manner AG you know because most of the
time when you introduce time travel to a
story there is going to be some [__] up
along the way where like to the ending
where it's just like oh that kind of
like plot didn't make sense the
mechanics didn't make sense s g is
pretty much one of the only examples I
can think of where you introduced time
travel and you managed to close the loop
while making it like seem like
everything was resolved yeah and they
and I think what was genius with Stein
gate is that they did all of that they
somehow managed to tie so many of the
Loose Ends perfectly into one knot while
not making the conclusion obvious for
people who was watching like you had no
idea how that show was going to end even
even as they like gave you all of this
information from like literally multiple
different timelines at the same time I I
I think I think the like I think the
impressive thing about this one isn't so
much what happened it's the fact that
they managed to tie everything up yeah
and they made it I remember liking it I
don't remember what happens but I
remember liking
it the only bad the only I'd say
negative thing about science gate is
that it is a slow burner especially the
first half I remember the first half was
so hard to get through if you make it
through that first half that entire
first 10 11 episodes is the buildup it's
also it's the SE it's the attack on T
season 2 and and I know it's I know it's
like intentional but it's so gray yeah
and Visually very like boring so it's
really hard to like sit there for like
10 episodes watch them in the exact same
location you're like a where are my
RG but like that was cuz I got into
anime and I was code guos is like full
goddamn colors and then I went to this I
was like oh this is a lot different why
why are the chin so round they're
talking a lot a lot of talk in the cool
way with the with the
[__] is that happen it's like what
next one death
n no I mean no the all for one the
ending is slightly different right it is
factually correct that the second half
of death toe is weaker than the first
half I think it's a good ending no I
think it's a good ending but it could
have been 10 times better if they if if
[__] Nia didn't exist yeah the [__]
was dog I know I I I agree that the
second half was weaker not even the
second half the second like the last
third weaker the I've re watched that
quite a few times is always just such a
like SLO in a different show yeah after
the obviously the big big thing yeah it
just kind of sucks but I think the
ending of death node did what it needed
to
um and I thought it was a good ending I
thought both the manga and the anime cuz
I've read both the manga and the anime
um both had different takes on the
ending and both did something different
and uh slightly prefer the manga ending
I knew you would Joey I [__] I just
think it's a better rounded and better
presented ending than I think the anime
is more cinematic which is why I kind of
prefer the anime ending yeah I I loved
uh the scene where he ran past his like
younger self with the death note I was
just like that was just like oh that's
an anime original I was like Ah that's
actually really well done I I kind of
like love the visuals of that um but
that's my that's just my opinion bro
yeah SC down it's all good all right
yeah ask class ask class okay I I like
the ending to this I I didn't finish
this show so I can't when he does the
final roll call not going to lie kind of
teared up okay I believe it I believe it
it was a feel good show it was it was I
think it was a way better ending than
what the show was expecting you to have
expecting you to see okay so I think
yeah this is underrated all right Cowboy
of iconic yeah go next one [__] off
Dragon Ball
Z I mean if we're not including GT I
guess but yeah we can just keep going
let's keep going we got nothing better
on I haven't finished Gintama yet all
right keep going yeah okay's going to be
yeah okay so we were right for the most
part yeah yeah I mean I L I don't think
endings matter that much I think as long
as you do whatever ending you'll be fine
after all of that whatever they don't
matter think about a lot of the shows
you like you remember call okay middle
bits and the feelings you had you don't
necessarily think of the part I'm not
saying the ending is everything but I
think it is an important part of a story
that shouldn't be overlooked well yeah
that's like saying that like any the
start is important every part of the
story is important but I I have
something more to add to this um because
uh I have just been playing cyber Punk
recently uh I played the uh played the
new expansion which I think is the best
kind of like cyber punks like thing that
has been released uh so far um and I
kind of realized that I think I hate
multiple ending games like you know what
I mean me too me too I actually kind of
despise it because the the the true
ending is always a lot of [__] you
got to do you got to look up a guide on
how to get it and you're like this sucks
why is the ending the the always the
good endings the on you have to go
through all the complicated [__] for
yeah because like I I I remember playing
through the original like the original
cyber Punk and the ending to me was
super unsatisfying uh and I kind of
realized that oh it's just because I
made all of like the worst choices to
possible I got like the [__] ending and
like to me like even like the fact of
the existence of multiple endings like
demerits the impact of having like one
single ending right cuz you can have
like I guess like a Canon ending a true
ending but just the fact that the the
user or like the viewer can choose their
own ending I think that detracts from
the impact of just there being one
ending do you get what I mean I I do
agree but then I I oh man I really like
that fear and hunger has multiple
endings I think it's really the fear and
hunger but I really like how they use
the multiple endings in that game but I
hated it in cyber Punk okay actually can
I can I preface the thing that I hate
the most is when you can't do any
choices that affect the ending until
literally like the last moment where
it's there's so many little things you
can do in like the very last seg cuz
then it feels like a copout it's like oh
you didn't plan for multiple endings we
just got to this one point and you felt
like we can add a bunch of depth if in
the last two hours of the game in that
vein then I think a game that does that
whole multiple ending thing really well
is Catherine because the the thing with
Catherine to get the multiple endings
it's literally from the very first
end matters yeah and I like how like
undertale does it like you know AE but
undertale did it in a really good
way immediately from the get-go seeing
different character interactions based
on what you're doing and locking you
into the worst the worst multiple
endings are the ones where it's
literally the last op where it's like
yes or no two different endings well
there like cyber Punk a lot of not not
all the endings but a lot of them are
what you answer in the last few moments
um yeah I well there's the depends where
you are there there are like so many
different endings to cyber punk though
yeah and I know there's a few way if you
do all the certain side quest you get
the true ending which is how it always
is but then I know there's like the when
you you can go to space or you can shoot
yourself or other stuff and I was like
man I felt like I've been locked out of
the good ending and all of these are not
fun yeah but I would have enjoyed it
more if I was put on a clear path that
is showing me that I'm going towards
something different from the start not
kind of figuring out like I remember
playing through the expansion and I was
just like this is actually the Cyber
Punk that I thought I was going to get
from the original game highly [__]
recommended by the way um because it's
[__] incredible how much they've
changed from the um from the first
initial release um and uh obviously
Idris Elba [__] kills it in this role
as well God it's he's [__] great but
you get I got to the ending and it was
like the way they closed out the ending
I got was so perfect to how like they
built up the characters and kind of like
metaphorically sent off all the
characters I was like this is [__]
great and then I read up on the other
endings and I was just like man if I got
any of these other endings with like
some of the major choices that I made I
would have been like I would have been
like
[__] I mean my I remember cuz I the
final big fight in that game at least
the base game I remember when I played
it it was so buggy yeah so I remember
thinking like especially the Epic final
boss and he stuck behind the wall and
shoot and I'm shooting him with a pistol
and I'm like man this is just this is
just not how I envisioned this to this
epic glad I Su the time into this yeah
it's just man it was yeah it was a bit
sad maybe I should go back and check it
out yeah and cuz and I just think I just
think for something very story driven I
guess like cyber punk I it almost
like it almost like like like I said
detracts from the impact of the ending
knowing that hey if you're not happy
with this one just go a different route
whereas you know you look at like other
games like for example like Last of Us
or you know God of War recently for me
those endings like stuck me because that
was the ending pleas send off to the
characters no no no redus no other Happy
Endings no other sad endings that was
the ending that we got right and that
was what made those endings stuck out to
me you know so yeah I think it's a
better way but I guess you have to why
do you like the fear and hunger endings
then I like it CU you have to the they
won the character specific so there four
playable characters and they all have
their own version which I which I like
because it utilizes their story to tell
you know not just a backstory here's
your character figure it out it's like
hey your character based off what we've
told you has this Mission if you go and
complete that mission you'll get a
unique ending which I really like cuz
it's it's setting the goals right from
the GetGo saying this is what you need
to do right and it's up to you if you
want to listen to that whereas I felt
that like cyberp Punk it's like uh
whatever whatever C Reef tells you to do
just do it yeah and then you'll figure
it out it's like okay okay I don't know
but I I haven't played the DLC and also
I haven't played it since when it came
out basically so I don't know it could
be completely different experience I
only presumably it is yeah um I I uh
okay first of all did you see you see
the uh you guys know I'm I'm a Rob
robber patson simp do you see he's
voicing uh in the new hiaki movie oh
yeah yeah did you hear him he dude he he
sounds insane in the dub yeah yeah he
sounds insane he doesn't sound like Rob
patson at all he does not it's insane
popped off uh I just want to say cuz I
watched this movie in Japanese yeah and
I heard his voice and I was shocked at
how good Rob Patterson got close to the
Japanese voice okay let's see Robert
Patterson the boy in the that's actually
kind of yo Willam def in it yeah will
the let go feel I'm actually watching
now yeah I might I might watch it yeah I
I I you know the movie actually CU I
think when I came on the show after I
watched this I said it was all right but
I think actually the more I've sat on it
the more it's grown on me yeah I think I
kind of like oh [__] I need to watch
this definitely July yeah dude watched
it I don't I don't think I'm not sure if
it's still in cinemas no I I was going
to watch it but yeah that's the one just
yeah just my what exactly are you your
mother she's awaiting your
rescue that's actually that's sick as
[__] good